celebrity family feared everybody let's
get together
i got my kids on the game show and by
the way they kind of sucked oh really
my kids were kind of bad and so it was
up to to you know to the adults to try
to bring it on home
they have something to friend gets that
you might say that's the biggest one
i've ever
seen zit
[Applause]
rob lowe thankfully kept it pg for his
appearance on celebrity family feud
premiering sunday on abc
he and his family take on terence
howard's squad
name something a kid uses to practice
the art of kissing
maybe their dog their pet
[Music]
a lot of them know how to play the game
and they want to do well but then you
know it don't work out that way
tell me something you'd hate to have
happen while you're making love in a car
[Music]
get rear-ended
this season celebs include jojo siwa joe
manganello
and yara shahidi the celebrity thing for
me is kind of special because
i'm always knowing somebody come on
player
be about it boy yeah when kanye was on
with
kim even his security came up to me it's
the most they had seen
kanye smile which is a testament to the
[Music]
show